to collect any belongings
please do not return to the building and
to give him permission to do so by
Council staff
please note that the meeting will be
audio recorded
please switch off mobiles or turn them
to silent
please note that toilet and hand washing
facilities are in the foyer area
members of the public are reminded this
is an official council meeting and the
applications will be debated according
to procedure rules set out in the
council's Constitution
members of the public can you please
note that you are not permitted to speak
at this meeting unless you've registered
to speak with the Democratic services
in this way everyone present will be
able to hear the debate and counselors
will be able to make an informed
decision can I please also remind you to
be respectful of all those attending the
meeting including other members of the
public counselors and officers
members of the public
while you are of course entitled to film
or take photographs during this meeting
can I please emphasize to you that this
should be done without disruption to the
meeting and can only be done from a
designated area in the public seating
can I please therefore ask you to raise
your hand clearly in the air if you wish
to take photographs or film this evening
thank you
[Music]
can I ask on the side there if you could
come into the middle that's the area
that we are allowed to do filming and
photographs please thank you
I appreciate your con your cooperation
on that one
members there is a need to use
microphones during the meeting
when I invite you to speak please speak
clearly into the microphone in front of
you
microphones are needed for the hearing
Loop and for the live stream
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the Constitution
I will ask for a show of hands for and
then against recommendations and we'll
also ask for a show of hands for those
wishing to abstain from the voting
item number one and two apologies for
absence and substitutes we have received
apologies for absence from councilor
Stuart Wilson
councilor Hoy will be substituting for
councilor Wilson
okay and we have uh councilor Brewer is
substituting for Council lacrosse other
way around sorry uh councilor Brewer is
absent and the council across is
standing thank you
Declarations of Interest
there is an
oh sorry other members attending I do
apologize
other members attending we have uh
councilor Steptoe councilor Williams
counselor cross Council sharp council
Mrs page counselor Newport councilor
Foster and councilor swearing do I have
anyone and Council against them
anyone else that I've missed out
[Music]
no thank you
okay uh agenda item four minutes of the
meeting held on the 18th of April
yeah sorry
that's next
so uh the minutes of the meeting held on
the 18th of April do I have any matters
of fact on that or can I take agreement
on those minutes please
are we in agreement I agree thank you
item five to receive Declarations of
Interest now I'm I can I just hold you
there a minute
um Phil drain uh would like to give a
little bit of guidance on this one
before we go any further please thank
you
good chair members I'm aware for this
item we have members who also are part
of Rayleigh Town Council and I'm
presuming that that is what the hands
going up so far is regarding because of
the community benefit fund proposed by
the applicant on this application uh the
thought process here is that it's likely
that those unrated Town Council of which
rally Town Council would benefit from
that Community benefit fund those on
ready Town Council would likely have a
pecuniary interest on this application
and the advice is that they should
therefore remove themselves from the
debate
um and not vote
yeah
[Music]
may I ask if that's the advice from our
solicitors
we don't have legal representation here
tonight I've had to take advice from
Phil drain officer
relevant to the department on this one
so I'm going to have to go with his
advice uh in the uh absence of any other
uh legal advice from our legal counsel
Trevor can I say I don't think that's
acceptable I think this should have if
there was a concern over this it should
have been sorted out with proper legal
advice before the meeting I've never
heard of people being
excluded from taking part in a meeting
on the basis that a council they sit on
May receive money
unfortunately this wasn't brought to our
notice until just before the meeting so
we actually haven't had a chance
to test the uh the opinion legally
Council ashore I believe you were first
thank you because it's not clear
for legal
can we ask for this to be deferred to
the next meeting please
[Music]
I know we've had advice but it's such
individual counselor to declare if they
feel they've got opportunity or not
peculing interest
so it's up to them if they won't declare
it or not
so whatever advice they can choose to
take it or not
I am aware that
um individual counselors have to declare
on their own volition as to what the
their position is and as a result of
that they take the um the wrap if
they're wrong so
give me a moment please
I'm being advised that we'd be best to
adjourn for five minutes if you wouldn't
mind and we will attempt to get hold of
our legal council in the
legal officer in the council and get
sorted advice so if you uh mind members
we also taking a job for five minutes
thank you
okay if we could uh re-rejoin the
meeting please
and Phil has managed to get in touch
with the uh standing in uh monitor
officer at Brentwood who will give us
the same advice as our own monitoring
officer would give us so over to you
Phil
and thank you chair I was talking to the
acting director of people and governance
who as uh councilories points out direct
is a monitoring officer at Roma Council
not been able to contact the monitoring
officer Rochester Council but
essentially we have a situation where
members are clearly free to declare
themselves so they have opportunity
interest in this situation it seems the
case that where Rayleigh Town Council
would benefit from funds that would come
from the applicant in this case that it
is likely as I think was being indicated
that people were putting their hands up
so that they had a peculiary interest
the advice from a local government
Association is that when you do have
Veterinary interests and that you do not
vote on the item and indeed that you may
remove yourself from the debate so it's
the only advice that I have on this item
it is for members to declare whether
they feel that they have a peculiary
interest on that basis
[Music]
can I just say that to stem me the
debate on this one that uh
members you've got to make up your own
mind on this so
if you decide to declare a peculiary
interest that is the decision that you
are making
um and if a later date you you declared
a non-pecuniary and there is found to be
a pecuniary interest then the onus is on
you so with that in mind
um can we now sorry can you explain what
you mean by those words
what do you mean by onus is on you well
there's a legal uh onus on
um for my understanding is that there's
a legal illness on the declaring a
pecuniary interest it's a
um
non-pecuniary is a uh something that is
um just within the Constitution
so there is no legal recourse on that
two members should there be any
ramifications from it that is my
understanding
if you believe that I'm wrong I am open
to challenge
no okay so with that in mind then can I
have any Declarations of Interest please
Council award
peculiar sorry another peculiar interest
in rainy Town Council because of the
addendum and the moneys that are going
to be ported to Rainey Town Council to
the value of 480
000 pounds I feel I cannot sit in this
meeting thank you
[Music]
customizing
yeah mine actually relates to the second
part I would to carry a non-pecuni
interest in fact myself United season
ticket holder
thank you Mr Stanley
thank you chairman uh no peculiary
interest uh as a member of the rodent
Council
thank you
sorry peculiar interesting okay thank
you
um with that in mind I've been asked if
we would move the agenda around because
the uh situation is those who have
declared a pecuniary interest and will
vote on this on the current
um LGA advice they are not allowed to
take part in the debate and they have
not they cannot be in the room so for
that particular item you will have to
you'll be asked to leave the room so
with that in mind if we could bring item
six
forward before item five uh are we in
agreement with that members
okay so if we bring item five forward
then so over to clear thank you
item seven I do apologize
[Music]
this application is a temporary planning
mission for a period of three years for
the sighting of 12 single story modular
buildings for welfare training and
storage use construction of a Bund
Amendment to the approved car parking
layout and construction of boundary
treatment in association with the four
grass football pitches grab your planned
permission on The Wider site last year
as you can see from the location plan so
I'll outline the air in red here so this
is the actual site location that we're
referring to here and the area outlines
um in a blue line which I'm just showing
here is the wider site ownership of the
uh for Southern United Football Club
so as you can see from the location plan
the site is on the Eastern side of
Sutton road so Sutter will be in here
incorporating Smithers Chase just in
this location here and also lies to the
north of Fossett's ways faucets which
ones along here
the site consists of approximately 0.53
hectares of land bordering this site to
the south of the residential dwellings
one and two Smithers Chase so they're in
this location here and we also have the
residential dwellings one to 11
timbergate Cottages which are here
to put the site into context as you can
see from The Wider site layer here so
you can see it's quite wide here just to
show you the whole extent of the wider
Southern United application site and for
both authorities
so the application site has been part of
a much larger development mostly within
the South End area for stadiums the
stadiums here and we've got some
football names and some residential and
Commercial uses as well
Planning Commission has been granted for
this development by South End and a
subsequent application for our
amendments to this remains under
consideration
so if I want to zoom in I'll just show
you what um has actually been approved
in our in our parts site last year
so this plan shows the development in
the Rochford area that was granted
permission last year and it included
four football pitches grass football
pitches a training set permanent
Training Center building
and flood attenuation pond that's here
and match day parking area
the current proposal was to cite 12
single-story modular buildings that site
for welfare training and storage use so
the largest four buildings would
measured 69.6 meters squared and that's
those located here
and five would measure 26.7 that's those
four in the five in the blue there two
would measure 12.9 meters squared and
one would measure 2.7 and that's that is
located here
there will be no greater than 2.6 meters
in height and would be sided to the east
of the attenuation Basin in the
approximate position of the approved
permanent Training Center building an
earth finally proposed the western edge
of the site extending from The Balancing
Pond to a height of 2.6 meters so that's
the Earth fund located here
the buildings represent a temporary
proposal to enable sufficient training
facilities to be provided adjacent to
the pitches as the formal boots and
laces facility will be closing to make
way for residential development which
will assist in funding the overall
Stadium development the permanent
Training Center building is intended to
be constructed within a later phase of
the wider Stadium development
so this is showing the the elevations
and also in purple so that the thick
sort of purple line that you can see
here
um actually shows the outline of the
permanent Training Center building that
was approved last year on the site so as
you can see these are the actual
buildings here
um this perspective here so I think my I
think it's running that battery
um so you can see here the Western the
Western elevation you've got um the
buildings lined up there so you can see
the two storage buildings there and the
other
um structures located there
um this one's a good perspective showing
um the attenuation Basin and then the
Earth Bond coming up here
um which looks to seek to mask some of
the buildings and from the Southern Road
perspective
thank you
this plan shows a training Car Park area
which received Planning Commission in a
similar form last year so changes are
sought to among other things increase
the size of the car Park area about
158.8 meters squared this increase in
size is partly to address the need to
provide an increase in disabled parking
bays and powered wheeler spaces the
parking area has also moved
approximately four meters closer to the
southern boundary and Now lies closer to
the attenuation Pond to that which was
approved with relocation the refuse
store also included I'll just um show
you a comparison I'm drawing so you can
see here and one to the the north here
that's the one that was approved last
year and this is the one that we're
currently considering so you can see
there's quite a lot of similarities
between the two
um the refuse store which was located
down here it's slightly gray which
should be great on the application from
last year was actually now removed um to
the North Western corner here and we've
got some more disabled Vapor vision and
there's just a slight more proximity
closer to
um this Southern edge here
so this plan shows the boundary
treatment that is also included for
consideration incorporate incorporates
three meter high World management World
mesh fencing and which so that's the um
ones that are highlighted green here
that's the world Bush fencing um part of
which is already on the site
um for those locations and then it also
has a proposal for
um Timber fencing or mounting rising to
a height of three meters so that's that
thicker sort of red line located there
so this perspective actually shows a
section drawing of the Timber fence on
the mounding and that's supposed to give
additional protection to the neighboring
Residential Properties at smithish Taste
because it's elevated to the three
meters
and final plan just to show so this is
the front elevation of the gate that
forms our entrance way into the parking
area so this is the um Green World mesh
fencing as well but in a gated form
the key material planning considerations
are Greenbelt character and appearance
residential amenity playing pitches
noise highways blood risk and
sustainable drainage
power drainage air quality archeology
refuse trees ecology and light pollution
so looking at Greenbelt the site is
located within the Greenbelt it is
considered that the buildings would
represent inappropriate development
within the green belt due to the scale
of development sort however very special
circumstances are considered to exist at
this site these are formed by seven
Collective things
the need to secure sufficient training
pictures and facilities at the watchford
site ahead of the closure of boots and
laces the fact that the training
facility is to Accord with small England
requirements need to be better than or
equivalent to existing facilities
that Southern United have a first team
and Academy team and the buildings they
seek are therefore more equivalent to
the requirements of high-end Club
that the proposal will result in less
floor space than both their current
facilities and the approved permanent
Training Center building
that the Earth Bond and green coloring
will assist in mitigating the visual
impact
that the buildings propose are temporary
and finally the training pitches and
facilities are fundamental to the
deliverability of The Wider Stadium
development
on this basis it's considered that the
very special circumstances identified
outweigh the harm identified it should
be noted that the car park layout is not
significantly different to that approved
and would not be considered to have a
greater impact on the green belt
looking at character and appearance the
temporary building is a single story
cabins commonly found on Industrial
estate however whilst not as aesthetic
this aesthetically pleasing as a
purpose-made building these are also a
common feature of football pitches the
Earthbound and green coloring would
assist in reducing the impact of the
buildings and the boundary treatment
using a combination of world mesh
fencing and Timber fencing is also
considered acceptable
the nearest neighboring properties are
located in Smithers Chase with those in
Sutton road also in close proximity the
buildings being single story would not
be overbearing or generate unacceptable
overlooking the parking layout
represents an improvement to number one
and two Smithers Cottages as it would
mean that it would be two meters further
away largely formed through a relocation
of the bin store to the Northwestern
corner of the parking area from the
South Western
a fence installed on bonding is also
proposed close to the boundaries with
one and two to reduce impact
notice application is the use of
Smithers Chase to access the development
and increase the usage of smitha's Chase
a private rooms owned by Roots Hall
limited is not considered to be
detrimental to the occupiers of Smithers
cottages
looking at playing pitches The Proposal
represents replacement training
facilities that would form equivalent to
or better provision in accordance with
the nppf
sport England does not raise an
objection and is in support of the
Amendments made during the course of the
application to increase the number of
temporary buildings on the site
looking at noise the current proposal
would not increase the level of activity
from that approved through the previous
application at this site therefore
Remains the case the proposal is not
considered to generate unacceptable
noise levels
so looking back at the car parking in
The Proposal would adhere to the parking
standards requirements the amendment to
the layout of the parking area is
considered acceptable such as image up
there again of the parking lot that
we're looking at before us tonight
The Proposal now includes the use of
smithish Chaser Smith's Chase and
someone just being here so with access
onto sudden mode here
rather than a fossick's way to access
the training pictures and training
buildings car park the whole proposal is
for a temporary three-year period and
this has been controlled by a condition
within the recommendation to ensure that
any impact could be reassessed after
this period in terms of its
acceptability
it would not include any greater
quantity of traffic movement than
previously considered just a change in
Access
during the course of the application a
transport technical note was submitted
which advises that the use of smoothest
Chase would not generate a highway
safety issue both Essex County Council
and Southend city council Highway
Engineers do not raise issue with the
use of Smithers Chase
on this basis it is not considered the
proposal would have a detrimental impact
upon highway safety through the use of
Smithers Chase
looking at flood risk and sustainable
drainage the applicant has submitted a
service order drainage strategy which
explains that the flows from the cabins
would eventually drain into the
attenuation Basin perforated pipes with
direct flows from the sub bases the
artificial grass and self-binding gravel
around the cabins towards a proposed
Inlet into the attenuation basin rain
will depart from the cabin roofs would
Connect into the blow ground pipes and
discharge through the same Inlet into
the attenuation basin the car park has
been constructed using asphalt which
would also connect up to the attenuation
basin Essex County Council lead local
flood Authority Rose no objections
subject to conditions
foul drainage so the foul water will be
disposed of by wherever wastewater
treatment plant located in the South
Western corner of the temporary training
cabins site without form of treated
water into the attenuation basin it's
been demonstrated that a public sewer
connection is not feasible due to the
temporary nature of the development and
the distance to the nearest connection
it is considered that an acceptable foul
water drainage strategy could be
provided here
air quality so the current application
will not generate any greater vehicle
movements than that already approved
whilst access to the site would be from
Smithers Chase rather than the faucet's
way for the current application it is
not considered that this would be likely
to generate any greater air quality
issues than previously considered
looking at archeology see archaeological
Works have taken place at this site but
this is in relation to the training
pitch location only further work is
considered to be required as advised by
Essex County Council and this has been
controlled by a recommended planning
condition
so looking at refuse the approved refuse
Storage Point is now proposed as
referred to area to the North Western
Corner located here
um this location is considered to be
more functional and raises no objection
so previously just to remind if it was
located here
there were no details of the design of
the intended refuse store such details
are subject suggested to be controlled
by planning condition to ensure that the
building has a modest input in terms of
visual amenity
looking at trees and ecology so tree
protection and the need for a method
statement along with ecological
mitigation was controlled by conditions
attached to the previously approved
application these conditions need to be
adhered to as Works to undertake this
application have commenced at the site
it is not considered necessary to repeat
these conditions here
and then finally light pollution there
was no proposal for the area to be where
the temporary training Builders be
located or the train car park to use
floodlighting whilst the development's
likely to have some form of external
lighting the design of such lighting
should be controlled by condition to
limit its impact
chairman this application is recommended
for approval subjects that conditions
outlined in the report and addendum and
also subduction amendment to condition
three so I'm just going to show you a
sort of
amendment condition three that we're
proposing tonight as well as officers
sorry notes
so this is the condition which is about
limiting it to three years and also
requiring a certain amount of government
to be taken away after that three-year
period
hmm
it's a bit small isn't it
there you go this will be better isn't
it
is that okay
so this condition
um is all about limiting the um
three-year time period um for
development and requiring certain things
to be removed at the end of that time so
originally as proposed on the addendum
um it referred to the need to remove the
12 buildings in EarthBound and at the
end of the previous uh the three-year
period and for the land to be restored
with its former condition we're also
adding in there in bold and they use a
Smither Chase to cease at that
particular Point as well and so that's
just a slight amendment that members
would also be voting on tonight as
proposed by officers thank you chairman
hey thank you
members as uh Claire has said there is
an additional addendum uh which I would
like to think that everyone has had a
chance to read through
[Music]
um there are no public speakers on this
item award members uh Council Mr Gooding
councilor septo and councilor Williams I
believe that councilor Steptoe which is
to speak
as usual you have five minutes when you
start thank you
thank you chairman giving me the
opportunity to speak to the
committee could I just quickly ask if
it's possible that they could rotate the
map that is on there anti-clockwise
please
okay
don't worry don't worry if you can't
um I've been involved with the
development on this site
since 2008 when I was first elected as
Roger District councilor and
applications go back for this site Way
Beyond there so this has been 20 years
in the making
and we're still discussing various
aspects of it I did leave some leaflets
there I don't know if many of the
members have picked them up
but one of the biggest concerns that I
have is around the entrance to Smithers
Chase
now the boundary
on this map is shown as it's in the road
not on the side of the road but in the
road this map is the detail map which
was produced in the 50s to fix
to fix the
footpath system
and you can see the little roundabout
where it says Smith has chased just
there and you can see where Smith is
Chase goes on you the faucets way is not
marked on there's because this is dated
back to the 50s but it runs off of that
roundabout and bear in mind that that
exit coming off of Temple Farm there is
the only exit from Temple Farm
industrial State and stock road because
stock road is a one-way Street all comes
there and just slightly off the the map
there to the left is where the cemetery
is
okay
now if I can refer you to the the
pictures if possible off to put the
pictures up
for me
okay that's the entrance to Smithers
Chase
as you can see it's a single Track Road
that's coming out onto the uh the road
there
if I could have the next picture uh go
down one more
that's the view looking to your left if
you were coming out to Smithers Chase to
the roundabout so you can see how close
the roundabout is
my concern and I don't think either
south end of our account or city
councils have addressed this or at each
County Council is if there is traffic
and that is a very very busy Road Sutton
road if anybody's driven that you will
know what I'm talking about
if there's traffic coming off of that
roundabout
coming into the picture from the top
right hand corner and there is a car
about to turn into Smithers Chase right
across the opposing traffic
and there is traffic or a line of cars
coming out of Smithers Jace that will
then block the roundabout
and it will feed right the way back
almost past the cemetery
so that's my single biggest concern and
I do not feel that either Essex County
Council and or South End city council
have addressed that particular issue
uh
this when this last plane application
came forward we did raise this is an
issue at that time and it was agreed on
the planned application that the road
new road going in would be off a
Fossett's way if I could have the other
map up please
okay
you just come out a little bit that's it
um that would be where the green line
comes down to the South
going into faucets Ray and a new
Junction around about put in at that
point there
there's obviously a much safer way to
deal with the issue
question is why is that happening why is
it changing I would suspect purely
because the sheer cost of having to put
it in
Smithers Chase as I've already mentioned
is a very single Track Road there are
residents that live at the end and I
don't disagree
one minute left okay thank you that they
would have any difficulties my concern
is as traffic comes out blocking the
road
with regards to the containers or the
Portable Buildings I'm pleased to see
that officers are going to lock in
the time limit please can we make can I
ask the committee to make that a fixed
amount and that that is not allowed to
slip over a period of time
as I say this application has had so
many various electrications and it's a
job to know which replication we're
actually speaking to I've lost track of
it I think there's six or seven
different applications that have got
planning permission on this site in one
form or another
thank you chairman I think that probably
covers everything I needed to say thank
you can I just clarify when you say
sixth amount a fixed amount are we
talking about fixed amount of time yes I
think that that is covered yes I think I
was pleased to see that so yeah um I
hope that the committee will actually
accept that and yeah lock it into the
application if it is agreed okay let's
have it thank you
[Music]
okay councilor Williams
as you know it's five minutes yeah I'll
let you know when we get to a minute
left yeah thank you thank you chairman
um
I don't have any problems with this
application whatsoever other than
councilor Steptoe pointed out the access
to the site last year we had an
application come before us and the
condition was put to that application
that the access be from what's its way
you can see these pictures now this is
nothing more than a farm track
this is the one that might point it out
if we can go to the picture of the faces
North on Sutton road
going up there it looks quite it's a
blind call of the approach so you would
have cars coming from the north towards
you just around that bend there is
Scott's Nursery which now causes
significant traffic issues now for I
presume that the
the ground will have coaches attending
there is no way that coaches will safely
be able to to go in and out of that
Junction so I would respectfully request
that that members place a condition on
this that the access should be as it was
last year via Smith via faucets way
that's it thank you very much thanks for
your time thank you thank you
okay members
cut of water
thank you very much chairman
um I would like some clarification if I
may uh a couple of things
um one of the the things that the
temporiness the the temporary area will
that be returning to car parking because
I can obviously say you've got all the
pictures the training pitches which will
remain and I assume that everything from
that will then stretch across the road
from the stadium and everything that is
going to be built subsequently over the
next three years
I would assume that or if I make a
incorrect assumption
foreign
[Music]
yes sorry just getting the relevant plan
up I think to help so
um to confirm I don't know if you
hopefully it's answered your question
but confirm if this doesn't so
um last year we approved the match Day
Parking attenuation based in a permanent
training since the car parks and
pictures they have commenced this
application so that could continue and
they could continue doing that over the
years to build that out this application
represents um an alternative to that for
the car Park area and this area just
here where the cabins will be located
um on top of where we have approved the
permanent training and facility building
so our three-year temporary permission
would require
um at the end of the three years the
removal of the temporary cabins that are
located here and an Earthbound which is
alongside and it would require
um the ceasing of the use of Swedish
Chase to access the development it
wouldn't require removal of a car park
um and the access road because those are
of effect
in some form when it relates to the car
park already been approved and could be
constructed or they already have partly
being constructed on site at the present
under the previous application we
granted last year okay can I just
further expand on on that question yes
um you've mentioned that that will be
used for Match Day Parking subsequently
no sorry that to us to avoid any
confusion this car park here is purely
for the training facility so the match
day parkings this Mass this large area
here
okay
um I mean obviously I'd like to Echo
some of the the points that were raised
in regards to Smithers Chase
um I mean just looking at it and knowing
it having gone past it you you'd miss it
if you weren't careful going along
um I think that's actually quite
dangerous
in that area I I don't understand how
highways have considered that to be
appropriate as an entrance to it in any
way because it's going to be continue to
be used as a training ground in that
area and there's going to be lots of
touring and frying because that's going
to be the work base
for South End United Football Club where
that's where the work is done the
training ground
so as far as I can see I believe it
should be reconsidered that Fossett's
way and the entrance should be in
Fossett's way a proper entrance going in
into the training ground and the
Smithers Chase should be
negated
thank you chairman
thank you for sure
thank you chairman I've got to do
an opportunity interest because I'm
Deputy Cabinet member for highways but
as we've got this we um I actually agree
with councilor or about fossets way
could we defer this to have a site visit
please
if I've got a second to put something
through so ever so because literally
some members who do not know this area
could we actually defer it on this is a
question
uh does anyone want to speak on the
deferment
cancer
yes
I I've delivered Parcels down
asthmics and it's really really tight
you you drive past it if you didn't know
where it was I think people don't know
where it is I think you should actually
have a site visit it is very very
not suitable
[Music]
Yvonne yeah
um just just to restorate that this is
an existing access that is actually
already used by vehicles
um the use that's proposed is just
purely for the training for the players
to come for the training facility
um it's a temporary consent
and we've conditioned it that the use of
Smithers Trace will actually be
ceased once that three-year consent is
actually
um
up so
um I think what we're trying to say is
is that you know this isn't a new access
that's being created as an access that's
already accessible by vehicles
um you know I'm we're here in obviously
members concerns but what we need to
also be reminded of the committee is
that neither South End city council
highways Authority have an issue with
the club using this access for this
purpose and Essex County Council who
obviously responsible to the road
Network adjacent to it also don't raise
an issue so
um
actually I think the the the photographs
that have been shown quite useful I
don't actually think that a site visit
will actually Show members anything
different to what's already there so um
yeah
thank you
um
if you don't mind I'm only just going to
add as well so on page 7.31 is the Essex
County Council higher Edge response
um and I just wanted to draw your
attention to although they are provided
informal comments
behind their comment they have based it
on looking at no recorded accidents at
the location the proposed vehicle
movements are low and the junction
visibility is all within design
standards so they've looked at that and
in addition to that concluding that
Smileys Chase is also a private road so
they have looked at that in order to
reach their conclusion that they don't
consider to be a highway safety issue in
association with with the access jobs or
make you aware
can I make a suggestion on this
um
I do understand some of the members
concerns on this and we've talked about
this before
one of the things that I haven't talked
about was the possibility of coaches
going down there
um
could we request a weight limit round
there to stop larger Vehicles using that
road would that be something that would
be what we we would have the power to
suggest the problem that we've got is
um is that this is an existing access so
already there could be larger Vehicles
accessing making deliveries to the
Residential Properties already Dan Smith
as Chase so
um that wouldn't actually be practical
because you've been put in a restriction
on something that is not going to just
be related to the use of this cup for
the club facility but for the wider use
of Smithers Chase so I don't think it
would actually be reasonable to actually
suggest that
okay I'm aware that other members want
to actually uh come in here
um but we have a bit of an issue here
because this is we've got
recommendations from the statutory
authorities and if the applicant should
decide then to appeal they've got very
good grounds to actually overturn what
we've actually uh what we actually
decide if we do make that a different
classification to what it is at the
moment catalog
yes thank you very much chairman I think
the main point here we're talking of
Smithers choice that is used as an
access for a couple of cottages ones and
twos and they may have a delivery they
may not the actual intensification will
be far greater Now using that access
there's no doubt about it because you're
going to have lots of uh guys going up
there in their Mercedes or whatever
they're driving up and down coming out
and doing whatever they do as young guys
do and I'm really concerned about this I
really am and I don't think it may be
that that road is the road but it is
totally unsuitable I mean as far as I'm
concerned from what I'm seeing and what
we're being asked to decide on tonight
is to accept that this road is
acceptable and in my opinion in my
opinion it definitely is not acceptable
because of intensification
okay councilor Stanley sorry guys thank
you
um I'd like to put a motion forward that
uh the Smithers Chase is not used and
that the road to faucets
to the site
would as a condition would have to be
would have to be instigated and the exit
or that road whether it be a left-hand
Turn Only into the
uh grounds and not a right-hand turn
into it
due to the fact of all the traffic that
is
going up and down foss's way and also to
make a exit from the ground and we've
been told that that ground belongs to
the football club whoever they may be
they can put a road in to go to the
roundabout at the B&Q
to put a track in there so that that
would alleviate all movement in
Smithers Chase
can I just refer back to the officers on
that please so
um chairman before us is a proposal to
you Smithers Chase we don't have foss's
way
um within this application for
consideration so it wouldn't be a
reasonable condition to impose as part
of the application so what members need
to conclude on tonight is whether they
consider the uses of this Chase
acceptable or not but that wouldn't be a
reasonable condition for us to impose as
part of this application
therefore I would like to put a motion
forward that uh Smith as Chase is not
acceptable to this planning application
I think we've heard from officers that
unfortunately that is something that we
can't do am I reading that right
I suppose it's really a point as to
where members want to go
because I know a site visit was being
put forward as well but um at the moment
um
you you understand officers perspective
we've got our Specialists advising us
that there's no concern with regards to
Smithers Chase
um if we were going down the line of
refusal that would make I think
potentially a bit of a difficult
argument on appeal without any sort of
specialist backup surrounding us and
where we have both counted to to two
authorities as well which you don't
often have we've got guys it's County
Council and South End city council both
raising no issue
um but obviously that's officer's
perspective
cancel away
um
um I'm possibly going against the grain
of most people around the table but um
in the report I can't see any Resident
opposing the use of the lane
we have the report from Essex highways
which we're always told we have to
take particular note of and it's very
and it's not really appropriate for us
to disagree with them
so I
I understand from
as I often do disgrave highways and I
understand the issue around the entrance
that Council Steptoe said in Council
Williams and other members but I think
on the basis of what's in front of us I
I think I would
be having to reluctantly support the
application
[Music]
are we speaking to the motion now
always speaking to other pointers
sorry I've held back on that at the
moment because I think it's relevant to
actually hear all sides of the argument
the reason being why is because we've
been advised that if we actually did
turn this down on the basis of the
access not being good that it's pretty
did certain that we lose a lot of people
right my point wasn't to do with this
motion it was to do with another part of
the application I'd like to hear all uh
arguments first and then we'll come back
I think if that's if that's okay
yeah okay because I think that
everything's rather intertwined here at
the moment and I think I'd rather
actually hear everyone's
views right before we actually uh take a
a stand on Castle Standish motion okay
well my my point was on the holding that
is around the site whether that was
being removed as part of the application
because if it isn't I would like the
advertising holding that was put up
removed as a condition of this planning
application because it was put up
illegally without planning permission in
the first place
it's not
no
um so there's permitted development
rights for for that hoarding to actually
be erected
um so it wasn't put up illegally it was
erected because it had planning consent
um and the technical the legislation
actually starts says that the
development needs to commence I think
it's within three months of the hoarding
being erected and they did commence
development on the site within that
period and the advertising that's on the
holding is as per the advert regulations
that's been checked by the enforcement
team probably about four years ago okay
but can we have a condition that that is
removed as part of this plan application
well I mean obviously the reason why
sites have hold input up is to actually
contain Development and Construction
Works within the hoarding so there isn't
any you know it limits any sort of
dust and Etc that goes out onto the
highway so um the Holdings there for a
purpose yeah once that development has
been done though that doesn't serve a
purpose anymore yes it is falling into
disrepute it's falling apart it's
correct it just looks like saw and I'm
just wondering if we can have that as a
condition of the planning that it is
either removed or maintained properly
yeah I don't I don't you know I'm not
disputing what you're saying um I think
I don't think it's reasonable to put it
on as a condition but I think what we
could do I mean officers could actually
speak to the club and ask them whether
or not it can actually its appearance
can be improved if that would assist
well I would prefer it as a condition
um because
um we know what what goes on with
buildings whether they want to spend
that money or not or whether they've got
the money yeah so I would like it
actually noted as a condition if that's
possible okay but bearing in mind that
this particular application is for the
temporary Porter cabins and not to do
the match Day Parking that still needs
to be developed which is where the
holding pretty much sits around so it
will certainly be relevant to ask the
holding to be removed once the match Day
Parking has been actually installed but
there's going to be quite a bit of earth
work to be done and I think actually the
holding does serve a very important
purpose for when that match day parking
is installed okay but can it be
maintained then to make it yeah we can
certainly speak to them now yeah we can
speak to the club about that okay thank
you thank you I've got two more members
that want to speak and I think we have
actually uh had this one for quite a
long time so I will restrict it to those
two councilors if that's okay please and
then we'll come back to council
Stanley's motion so councilor Myers
uh the only thing I would say and
perhaps the club could actually confirm
is one way or the other I I can't even
see if the players turning up in coaches
most of them are going to be living
locally turning up their own private
cars so I can't see where we got in
coaches coming in out because we're
saying it's not going to be used for the
match today
so yes our grant is a very tight
Junction but we've driven past it loads
of times seeing cards coming out of it
and it's never caused a problem when
I've ever driven past
thank you a council award thank you very
much chair chairman for allowing me to
come back
um I just need another bit of
clarification if I may
um you mentioned that Smithers Chase
will be temporary use
uh for the three-year period
you can confirm that subsequently
another entrance will be used
so it Remains the case that they've
still got the permission for the faucets
way access and force its way roundabout
and that still is within their phase to
actually construct it's just later down
the line because obviously they need a
certain amount of funding and payment to
obviously build out the main with a much
wider development we've got going on
here so the smoothest Trace access and
usage at the minute we have controlled
for a three-year temporary period at the
end of that three year period we have
controlled that use of this Chase should
cease and obviously later down the line
they will look to build their permanent
training building anyway okay if I may
then say chairman that I I would
actually agree with uh what councilor
Hoy was saying with regard to the
highways issues
that you know we need to be quite
careful with the advice we're getting
from statutory bodies and the fact that
it is limited to three years
is a very important factor and I think
you know that is something that we have
to emphasize and that has to be a very
strict condition
and that then places the onus on the
owners Southland football club to ensure
that a proper access is created
in the proper way
thank you Jim thank you
um I've just got one question
um and it's unrelated to anything that
we've got at the moment uh the foul
water drainage we've got a temporary uh
we're told it's a temporary um uh
pumping or a treatment station there
that is coming out at the end of three
years is that right because I understand
that the uh the proposal was not near
enough to the main sewage to a TBO to
link but I don't know what the ongoing
issue is with that
[Music]
period
um but I don't consider that potentially
necessary because at the point when they
need to construct the permanent Training
Center buildings obviously a much larger
operation and it will need a permanent
connection at that particular point and
that permanent connection
um is going to be roughly
um around about there I think it is and
it might be further up it's in Fossett's
way along faucets way and that's where
the whole of the stadium development
will connect up to so it is proposed
later down the line so it's not a
condition to remove the wastewater
treatment plant at that point but
obviously inevitably when the cabins are
removed and this permanent building will
go in it will need a permanent
connection at that point um
thank you
um councilor Stanley would you like to
uh verbalize your motion please first of
all chairman may I point out that the
Sutton Parish Council on page 7.31 has
said that the Smithers Chase is a single
Lane
and totally unsuitable for in vicious 30
cars that will bring the Thai access
point to Temple Farm round about and
something about that thing
that is their statement from Sutton
Parish Council who objects to that you
can see that first of all thank you
um getting back to my
motion or uh
of the the Smithers Chase uh is
unsuitable
for this amount of traffic and that uh
Fawcett's way should be the right way of
going about
entrance into the
into the areas of South End training
ground and an exit from an only a
left-hand turn into that from Fawcett's
way
and another entrance or exit be made
to go into Fawcett's way at another
Point thank you okay Sonia could you
possibly read that back to us no no no
no no cannot so
right so can I have a bit of clarity on
that then please because I think we're
we're just just say that okay let's I'll
put it in plain English uh Smithers
Chase is unacceptable
as a entrance into the
plane area
and that faucets way should be used as a
way in
and away are different
places
okay do I have a second there
okay cancel tonight
so those in favor
[Music]
Sonia could you just read that back to
us please
[Music]
so if I understand correctly uh
councilor Stanley you're moving emotion
that set that Smithers Chase is uh is an
unsuitable access and that faucet um
fossip way should be the access used
yeah okay so
everyone understood that
okay I'm being asked that as part of
your motion then do you consider that uh
the grounds for refusal of the
application
yes
let's refuse all that the Smithers Chase
is not suitable for
the traffic that's going to be used on
that and where it is where it is as an
entrance in Sutton road
I guess or not you're still happy to
have second that yeah okay right so we
go to a vote then
those four the motion please indicate
okay thank you hands down
those against
any abstentions
[Music]
here
so we have two for the motion nine
against and one abstention that motion
is lost so now we go to the substance of
the application and
the recommendation is that the planning
permission be approved subject to the
conditions set out on pages 7.1 through
to 7.9 of the report and on pages three
to five of the addendum
[Music]
right there's a slight variation to
condition three at the end of the first
paragraph uh I'll read the whole
paragraph actually because I think
that'd be clearer uh this condition
threes this permission shall be limited
to a period expiring three years from
the date of this permission at which
time the 12 buildings and Earthbound
hereby approved shall be removed from
the site and the land restored to its
former condition on or before the expiry
date the use of Smithers Chase to cease
at that point unless the renewal of his
permission has been sought and obtained
do we understand that yep okay so can I
have an indication of those in favor
because on the final Amendment it says
smoother's Chase was to be put back
was to be taken out of it after three
years
so absolutely so where you've read that
out saying that this is what I read out
yeah that's physical yeah there's a
there's an inclusion in there that
that's why I read it out I think there
was a slight variation in sorry the
reading in comparison to the one on the
on the screen but it is virtually the
same it reads virtually the same just in
this one yeah
and go back to get planning to use it
again with what you've read out right
so this would control and ensure that
the use of Smithers Chase for the
purpose with this application is
approving would cease after three years
so members do you want me to read out
what's on the screen
now if you're happy with proceeding on
that yeah okay
sorry thanks a lot
thank you chairman yeah I understand
you've added that in subsequently
tonight that's the important thing
because it exists in the addendum you've
added that in subsequently thank you
yeah we're great okay thank you right so
members those in favor of the no sorry
oh I need a second sorry
who are we going with the council award
okay thank you
groups okay so now those in favor please
indicate
okay hands down those against
okay any absentions
thank you that is 10 for no one against
and to abstention that application is
approved thank you members
[Music]
I'm being asked if we can adjourn for
five minutes just to be clear on this
pecuniary interest issue
so we will return for another five
minutes if you don't mind
members can I ask you to reconvene
please
[Music]
okay members can we get started again
please
now before we get going
um Phil drain is just going to give us a
little bit more further Clarity on the
legal position please thank you
thank you chair members I appreciate
your patience on this one um I think
it's important just to
they're not loud enough okay thank you
for your patience members
um I think it's important that we make
decisions in in the most uh appropriate
way in terms of public perception and
just making sure that we're comfortable
with the advice that's being given I
have been able to speak to the
monitoring officer at Rushford Council
and I'd suggest
um that I just clarify the point around
Machinery interests in particular just
so that we're clear for the decision
making process obviously it is up to
individual members to declare uh whether
they think they have an interest or
otherwise but I'll come on to that
um so it is a matter for each member to
determine individually the advice being
given to committee members is that being
a member solely of raylee Town Council
does not constitute a disclosable
pecuniary interest as defined by the
relevant authorities
um including disposable pecuniary
interests and the regulations of 2012
therefore members are able to
participate in the debate and
potentially vote depending on their
perspective of whether they hold an
interest however given the facts as
we've set out within the addendum and
the community benefit fund that's being
offered to Rayleigh Town Council it may
be that members need to consider whether
or not that they have a predetermined or
biased in respect of the application in
terms of what the right decision is so
for instance a permission would mean
potentially that the community benefit
fund comes to Reading Town Council and
therefore members of raily Town Council
many to consider whether that in any way
gives them an interest or potentially
predetermines in some way the decision
that they're making
um if they're unable to approach the
application with an open mind they must
not participate or vote so again I think
it's important that members are aware
that it is there position their viewers
to whether they hold an interest and
whether or not they participate and vote
and therefore I think that is the advice
that is being given to members on this
basis I would just say and this may come
up in debate that clearly the community
benefit fund is not relevant to the
planning decision that we're making this
evening on the basis that it's outside
of any section 106 it's not part of
anything that makes the application
permissible or required
um but in the sense of the potential
conflict that exists if members are on
railing Town Council that's for those
members to consider whether or not they
want to participate in the debate and
indeed vote
thanks chair
thank you Phil uh before I ask the
officer to present the report
um members I assume that you have all
read the addendum relating to the
application
okay thank you
um okay
Roberta oh well thank you
oh sorry hang on
councilor
thank you very much indeed chairman
um basically only advice given and my
own personal view I feel it is better
for me to actually withdraw for this
meeting before anything is said
whatsoever I feel it is the safest
course of action for me to take in
regards to the interests that I have
pertaining to the whole of this
particular application so I I will ask
to be excused
from this meeting now and okay thank you
thank you I appreciate your calendar and
yes you are excused thank you thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you chairman good evening members
write this application relates to
proposed 30 megawatts solar fan within
ancillary infrastructure intend it
operates over a 40-year period the solar
fan would generate enough electricity to
supply around 11
000 and 11.5 000 homes
with electricity and it would save
over 13 tons of CO2 emissions per annum
in terms of the overall reduction and
the impact of the development in this
sense I'm going to show you a few plans
if you bear with me there's quite a bit
to get through but I'll try and make it
as painless as possible so the first
plan I'm going to show you is the just
to highlight
the site area here which is in Red so I
just wanted to show this plan in terms
of The Wider context of sites so here
we've got the settlement of really
um that envelopes a site to the east and
north we've got the very prominent a127
east west
uh
a table Road here we've got the a13
coming up serving and then up onto the
a130 here
and then we've got the a1245 coming
from off the fairground interchange and
that road there would take its Aurora
michelin's Farm the council's allocated
employment site and also partly Gypsy
travel site is here
South and off Ben Fleet of these areas
here so just to the just to confirm then
this site although you can see what its
relationship is the wider built form and
the infrastructure in the area it is
designated green belt
if we can move on to
slide two please
so this plan here so the site is edged
in red here
so it's not entirely Square
so the size actually is 40.2 or hectares
and that equates actually approximately
to 130 Acres inside area so although on
the plan it just looks a rectangular
area it is quite uh significant in its
scale
so in terms of scale and distances along
the North Boundary
from here
to here it is
1296 meters
and from north to south centrally
here it's approximately 400 meters at
its West aspect so it's here actually
that's where I've been measuring there
emphasize that the site does not extend
all the way to the uh interchange so
michelin's farm would be here so this
area here is not forming the application
site and neither is this area here
between the bottom of great Whitley Road
and great weekly farm this is the
vineyard area where the footpath crosses
it and some members will attend the site
visit would have viewed the site from
that style there and there's a picture
later on to show you under the visual
impact assessments
so I'm just going to point to
some of the features so the length along
the a127 along here
is 757 meters whilst the staggered band
will be to the east which is this
boundary here
and it's all in this entirety 639 meters
if you follow the boundary in this
fashion
so I'm just going to point out some of
the features on the plan
um so we've got obviously really
settlement here and we've got weekly
Woods here which is managed by the
Woodland Truss
and then we've got a great weekly Farm
here which is we'll be mentioning later
on
um which is a listed set of buildings so
it's a designated Heritage asset here
I just wanted to pinpoint actually the
great weekly Farm
from this point here
is over 200 although it looks quite
close because it's on on a map it's all
the from this point here
it's roughly 387 meters at the East
aspect of the site from great weekly and
241 meters from news pastels passed away
so the site as you see from the next
slide is split into Parcels from one day
parcel so just to give you an idea of
the um context of the site
so we'll move on to the third slide
please
so here I've mentioned it before then so
you can see now the relationship just a
zoomed up version so you can see that
the electricity substation is here and
on the layout plan which you'll see in a
minute is that the there's going to be
like a
the main infrastructure in terms of
Transformer station and the control area
is going to be here with cabling coming
this way and
servicing the electricity substation
here so sorry um this was when some of
the members on the site visit stood then
and they looked over the site in this
direction so there's quite a distance
actually then from here to here across
that Vineyard area and this is the only
rights of way but this right Subway for
path number 24 if I remember doesn't
actually cross the site it just crosses
from the bottom of great weekly Road on
that style downhill towards the a127 and
this is an ornamental Pond I think
that's beachcroft Farm I think that
belongs to just just another feature on
this plan just before we move on you can
see the it's worth noting the Contour
point so when one looks at the site and
I've stood on the site in various parts
of it it looks relatively flat
um but as you see from the contour line
there it says 22 meters already above
Northern State and then that's 30 meters
so there is a rise in the land as you go
from east to west southwest to Northeast
really so although it's not all that sir
double actually on the site and I think
that's because you know we're talking
about such a long distance you know
talking about a thousand meters odd here
so that incline isn't all that obvious
um if you'll go to the next slide please
the modular rain layouts just to show
you the pattern so I mentioned that
these it was split into Parcels or
parcel one the site access actually is
coming in here
so parcel one
I don't intend to show you the zoom that
plans but in each of these Parcels
pretty much there's a Transformer
station
the Transformer station for parcelon is
somewhere here near to the access and
the general pattern is the little
Transformer stations will be located in
the corner of each field culminating in
a greater mass of buildings in this
corner here strategically cited because
there's already some tree uh growth here
so they can be screened here and also
strategically it's located close to the
where the cabling from this point here
will be taken to the substation which is
outside the application site so just to
say on this plan they'll be arranged in
rules facing south orientated at angle
of 20 degrees at a height of three
meters they'll be secured onto metal
frame either piled into the ground or
surface mounted anchors and the next
slide shows the profile of the actual
panel then so there we go so what we
call the Leading Edge of the panel
um is roughly not 0.7
vertical relative to the Grand level so
you can see how they will be effectively
fitted on
uh these stanchions I would call them
really
um and either those will be piled into
the ground
um or there'll be surface vanted in
terms of probably like a concrete pad
and bolted onto the pad so effectively
they'll be
sitting lightly on the on the site
really so you know very different traps
from the from that from a building
operation as such so
the I'm just going to mention there are
seven Transformer stations in total
within the corner of the respective
parcels
um and they'll be underground cabling
um
and the proposed construction I was
seven days per week during the
construction period from 7 30 until 1800
weekdays and 8 30 to 1800 weekends
I'm going to show you now an access
point to the site which is quite
important
right okay let's have a look I think
here's plan number zero zero seven
okay it's not all that discernible there
if you can zoom in
um
here we go so the access point is here
um initially there was an Eastern access
point but that's been done away with so
just explain really around the access
um as in the report
that comes access to the site has
achieved from existing field access
Junction located off the east Bank
character of the a127 south end of the
South End zero Road
I want to just explain the the green and
the
the brown shading so what we know is is
that
on a county level there's going to be
infrastructure improvements to the fair
Glenn interchange
so the area
marked in ground
has been produced by the applicant just
to demonstrate that
that this scheme effectively has been
designed to coincide with the
improvements to the fairground integers
what what The fagline Interchange would
involve is that it would involve removal
of hedger along here to provide
improvements to this
area here
so this is permanent works that are
required in connection with the
fairground interchange which is not part
of this application and the green bit is
the temporary works that are required
temporary improvements that are required
uh in connection with this particular
scheme I'll explain a little bit as we
go along
so if we go
chairman if I may
um
I have no idea what's green and what's
Brown at the moment right so yeah this
brown bit here yeah I'm kind of blind to
remember oh sorry this this area next to
the red line which I'm outlining now I
can't say red either right I don't know
what to suggest really but can you see
the actual pointer then counselor
[Music]
so this can you see the pointer this
area I'm going along now shakedly is
going to be an area where there's to be
some improvements
to the highway Edge in connection with
the fairground interchange improvements
down here so it does implicate if you
like the the raw that comes up onto the
a127 offer interchange so this
represents Road Verge clearance of
vegetation
coinciding with the fairground
interchange Improvement works and the
bit I'm outlining now
here
our works that will be temporarily
undertaken in connection to provide
access for this scheme during the
construction phase that's the best way I
can explain it okay thank you if we can
move on to
plan zero nine please yeah so this is
quite important this one so this this
drawing here as you then as you can see
from the reading so
this coincides with what I've just said
really so but what this actually this
drawing also shows is what we call the
deceleration
taper so when Vehicles will have to
approach this site obviously from an
Eastward sorry from a Westerly direction
from The Interchange if they're coming
down from raw Earth or they127 or the
a 13 they have to come this way don't
they so when the construction phase are
taking place there'll be slowing
movements here so this is
um like the deceleration taper and this
shows in in effect the sweet path
analysis of construction lorries so what
this drawing shows is
the sweatpath analysis of sorry this so
let's point to the sweatpath analysis of
lorries and construction vehicles as
they're coming into the site
and then the the threat path of vehicles
coming out of the site and this is the
actual acceleration taper so there has
to be enough room within that strip
which will form part the highway to
enable all these safe movements to take
place and this scheme has been
um undertaken and is coincided with what
we call a road safety audit stage one
that's been tested
unscrutinized if you like an
interrogated by Essex County Council and
its consultants and this scheme actually
now is RSA stage one compliant so if you
press move on to the next slide
I think it's actually
um
yeah and then again what this shows is
is just within the area of the
acceleration and deceleration tape that
is
some of the root protection areas of
trees that will be affected and in the
report it doesn't make mention of
certain types of trees
um by the classification that will be
um
affected to some degree that's covered
I'll try and come back to that under the
main section on trees
so
um just plan 11 please so yeah this plan
here does show so this is the actual
plan that was approved this a county
Mata plan so basically my understanding
of the fairground interchange is to
create well a more a safer access that
eases the the flow of traffic at that
interchange
um in a more appropriate manner stop it
clogging up at Peak floor times and
things like that so if we move on to
plan 12 please so I don't know whether
you can zoom that's up Claire but it
doesn't matter if you can't
okay so this is an illustrative
landscape master plan and what in in
essence the brown area here
shows the
these will be new access tracks but they
seem to coincide with the field edges So
currently right now what we've got here
there's a series of ditches Within These
Fields particularly along here and here
so these tracks will be required to
service the plants and equipment so
there's quite a lot of track going in
made out of porous materials now the
green bits that we see is the planting
of new Hedgerow along the field margin
So currently there's some pictures to
show you but currently other than in
this area here and there's a few trees
dotted around it's quite a vast
open site and I think that what the
report says about this as well is in
terms of biodiversity net gain and the
illustrative master plan which this is
is that it aims to do well two things
really which is to
minimize the visual impact of the solar
panels themselves as the
the panels in terms of visual be broken
up into these parcels and they'll be
screening but also as members will note
from the report there's a biodiversity
net gain compared to the to the sort of
Matrix on biodiversity of about a plus
140 so they'll say the dewal purpose so
they the idea is is to
um
reinstate what was probably before
probably you know the 1940s at post-war
these fields were turned into much
larger Fields so there's a sort of a
reconvening of properly what the
original field boundaries were
okay
um applied to the plans whether they're
not games right I'll just show you some
pictures before we go on to what the
main planning issues are and I discussed
those I'll give you we'll just leave wit
for those plans to open up and I'll just
I'll just talk through these plans
really
so this this plan
um is taken so
these dwellings here actually are weekly
Woods would be up here
that isn't that actually isn't
um
great weekly Road or great Wheatley farm
that is more up this way so that's just
a shot looking from the highway they
want to seven across part of the site I
think that's parcel four let's give you
an idea of scale we'll just move on to
the to the next slide which is 015
foreign
[Music]
yeah
if we can't open all of them they just
look
[Music]
how about we open uh can we go to
28 so can we are we having trouble
opening any of them or
perhaps what we'll do is I'll carry on
and talk through the
um main issues but there is one
photograph that I would like to show you
which is relative to the Viewpoint from
the bottom of great Wheatley road which
is I think it's about number if we go
back
can you see that um the reference to
visual
great weekly gwr
you can see that play GW Summit okay
let's see if this will open
but what the photographs that we can't
open unfortunately at the moment is they
show you various shots across the site
from
uh there was a view of the train going
past there's a view looking North
there's a view looking north to south
you could see the boundary of the
hedging along there once you send so
then to trying to portray really
um the screening within the site but
what I'll do is as we're trying to open
the picture of I think what we'd like to
do is show you the picture of the site
from the bottom of great weekly road
which is quite a key focal point but if
we in the meantime until we can open
that press I'll just go through some of
the planning issues then and summarize
what they are and we'll come back to
that photography that GW app we can open
it so we've
summarizing the reports of the key
considerations as members will note
starts at 3.12
and ends at 3.208 so it's quite a uh a
meaty report isn't it
um so the Highlight within paragraph 312
is the key section the section 386 of
the plumbing and compulsory Purchase Act
so when we're talking about the
principal development I suppose we're
looking at
the fundamentals of planning policy that
requires local authorities to determine
applications in accordance with the
provision of the development plan
and less material planning
considerations in the kit otherwise
um
on the on the planning policy framework
which obviously is in favor of
sustainable development but as members
will note from the the report the
council does have a policy relating to
renewable energy which is the nv6
large-scale renewable it doesn't
actually Define in terms of Site Area
watches large scale
but in terms of the council's on
policies then it doesn't presume against
large-scale renewable energy per se but
seems to obviously want to avoid
sensitive sites like the crowd chestery
sssis
um areas of of ecological importance so
the starting position is is we're
looking at the green belt issue so as
members will note from a report
that in definition terms the national
planning policy framework paragraph 147
to 149 doesn't list large-scale
Renewables as one of those exceptions
does it within the policy so as a
starting point the
um
there is definitional harm because of
the definition it is inappropriate
development there is also the the other
hand by the very presence of the
development within the Metropolitan
Green Belt which is enough in itself to
trigger a second other consideration of
harm
and paragraph 335 of the report speaks
to the planting proposals which
mitigates the visual dimension of Han
paragraph 3.26 speaks to localized harm
in visual terms and references made to
the erosion of openness by existing
developments including road Network and
michelin's farms and also pylons so in
effect what I'm saying members is is
that it is green belt but when you're
assessing the actual
magnitude of the actual ham
from the developments you've got to also
consider that the context of sight in a
swider setting and what other
infrastructure if you like has also
already had an impact on that landscape
but it's not to say it isn't harmful but
we've got to take a view of that
coinciding with that harm as well so
it's it's false to say that very special
circumstances need to exist don't they
to outweigh these hands and this as
members will notice discussed at 3.27 to
3.5 to other reports which relates to
the waiting and effect attribute
attributable to the other factors which
in themselves would need to constitute
very special circumstances and the key
issue of course is whether the very
special circumstances without where the
green belts are although the harm
expressed is at the lower end of the
scale
3.29 highlights the score for local
planning authorities to Define what
amongst the very special circumstances
although the test is a Higher One
what are the factors amounting to very
special circumstances so this is defined
in paragraph 151 of the national
planning policy framework that
recognized that many renewable energy
projects will comprise in appropriate
developments the same paragraph then
goes on to mention circumstances
including the wide environmental
benefits a source set of increased
renewable energy production
the public benefits of clean solar
energy attracts very substantial weight
and mounts to very special circumstances
necessary necessary to outweigh the
substantial hands the green belt so in
this case members of Northwood have
clindamy report the following so what
are the special circumstances in this
case well the land available in Rochford
um is limited so the total land mass of
the district is 16 800 hectares 12 763
which is Metropolitan Greenbelt with 12
986 hectares constituting areas of
psychological importance the site
selection and suitability is therefore
limited for developments of this scale I
think that's what my reports are saying
flooding a landscape issues are
constraints on many other sites in the
district connections the grid
availability is another one
paragraphs three three point three three
to three point five two speaks to the
benefits of the proposed development in
terms of the policy position including
including paragraph 1.52 and 1.58 of the
framework and appeal decisions which
support and which gives significant
weight to renewable energy production
which in a vast number of appeal
decisions are shown to outweigh the harm
to the Metropolitan green belt and other
ham
in this case by the biodiversity net
gain this is a feature of the
development through the planting of new
hedges around parcel boundaries and tree
planting around the Transformer station
and also material to this decision the
principle of solar technology and solar
developments within the Metropolitan
Green Belt has already been established
by Roxford Council on previous occasions
including planning reference
21.00605 ful which is the solar farm
application at South fanbridge which as
I recall was slightly larger site than
this site
3.52 the report recognizes that there
are other matters which also must be
considered in the planning balance and
are dealt within the reports
so the landscape impacts
okay that's fine
so the report mentions the landscape
impacts and I think the conclusions the
Landscaping practice is that there will
be impact this is a shot
during the winter months looking down at
the site now the summer one would be
better if we could open it but if we
can't that's fair enough it's the next
it's the slide before it's Gia summer
can you see that gwr summer
yeah
so we can open this somewhere when it's
not opening but basically the site is is
here basically so this is the
intervening Vineyard area and the site
is here michelin's Farm is here and the
site wraps around the back so I think
basically in summary then the report
accepts that there is some harm to the
visual visual uh
uh landscape here in terms of visual
harm people will see this site from the
foot path but it's not a National Trail
so
um if it was a national trail with many
people using it this receptor point
would be more sensitive by that nature
so we'll just move on and try and
summarize so the landscape
benefits yeah
so what we've concluded is is the
landscape ham as well in in addition to
the visual hand it's not sufficient it's
it's of negligible uh it'll be
negligible in real terms
I'll just move on
the impact upon the Heritage assets is
discussed in detail in 3.87 3.100 of the
report which is great weekly fan
just before I finish and come to the
recommendation it's important to say
that part three paragraph three no no
reports are significant it makes
reference the paragraph two or two of
the framework which talks about weighing
the harm against the public benefits so
the impact upon the Heritage asset of
great weekly Farm there is a harm as uh
summarized also and confirmed by Bill's
Heritage conservation of Essex Council
but the harms at the lower end of a
scale members will then note that I've
drawn then on the public benefits and
also the planning balance so planning
law tell us we have to apply a balance
in the decision-making process and I
think how the report concludes is is
that there are many aspects of this
scheme in terms of the contribution to
sustainable energy production consistent
appeal decisions also that actually must
carry significant weighting they
outweigh the hands the green belt and
also weigh the ham to the Heritage asset
so my recommendation
is subject to the conditions attached
that permission be granted
um
subjects to the 26 conditions are set
out in the recommendation thank you
[Music]
six
years
[Music]
okay thank you for that
sorry for the delay there just taking a
bit of advice
um we have
two public speaker speakers on this item
and I'd like to start off by asking Mr
George Wellman uh to please come and
take a place at the microphone and you
have five minutes to speak from when you
start
I'll give you a one minute warning when
you get to it
just foreign speech um just one small
correction in the great um introduction
we had there in relation to the access
point so it's actually the other way
around so the the Western access which
there's all about two access points East
and Western the Western access point was
the one that we went in with originally
and that was the main access point for
the application
that was the one that Essex highways
objected to we then moved the
application access point to the Eastern
access which was also shown on screen
the officer's report is correct in that
in that findings and also one of the
drawings shown uh did show the correct
access as well I just wanted to make
that plan before you make a judgment so
that that access you're looking at there
is the is the Eastern access
and there was another slide which showed
um that is the sorry that is the Eastern
access the other one you looked at was
the West access that's the access that
we're going forward with and that's the
access which is agreed with Essex
highways thank you yes I think the
officer made that clear so thank you
very much
my name is George weilerman and I'm the
head of planning for the applicant
overpower and before I come into my
speech I received a short statement from
Essex Friends of the earth which uh they
request has read out this reads as
follows
I'm sure you're all aware that climate
change begins to cause immense suffering
in the poorest countries of the world
and is now impacting us here in the UK
research by the University of bath shows
young people are becoming increasingly
concerned about what the future holds
for them with over half of 16 to 25 year
olds suffering from eco-anxiety
never before has the need to make the
shift to Renewables technology being
clearer just over a week ago the threat
of Russian sabotage of our North Sea
energy infrastructure and another reason
to generate as much electricity as we
can on land
we demand growing for copper and other
minerals it's essentially limit the use
of such materials through reduced
cabling by generating as much
electricity as we can close to the point
where it's consumed
for those reasons and many others we
must welcome the prospects of so much
electricity being generated so close to
Rayleigh
and this scheme Builds on the successes
of earlier solar Farms by increasing the
biodiversity of the area this is exactly
the kind of project young people want to
see and can make as proud as a town of
our efforts to secure a safe future for
all I hope you feel able to approve the
section scheme and then following on
from that just starting with my my
speeches the applicant
the policy position and support for
renewable aged generation in the UK is
clear
the 2020 energy white paper describes
solar as a key building block for the
future energy generation mix the mppf
provides a presumption in favor of
renewable energy and confirms that the
planning system should support renewable
and low carbon energy
the revised draft MPS en3 describes
Renewables as an essential element of
the transition to Net Zero the 2021 Net
Zero strategy States the UK will be
powered entirely by Clean energy by 2035
with infrastructure needs to be employed
and deployed at an unprecedented scale
the British energy security plan has an
intense anticipated five-fold increase
of solar capacity in the UK from 14
gigawatts to 70 gigawatts by 2035.
the making Essex carbon neutral plan
sets out a target of 1.43 gigawatts of
large-scale solar by 2030 as well as
setting a Target Supply
all of the County's energy from
Renewables by 2040.
Rochford sustainability action plan sets
the requirements to generate 100
megawatts of renewable energy in the
district by 2030 which aims to achieve
carbon neutrality and where possible
carbon negativity continuing support
large-scale renewable energy projects
the benefits provided by the proposed
development are all substantial and
evidence with a capacity of 30 megawatts
radio solar farm will help meet the
critical challenge attacking climate
emergency and supporting local and
National Net Zero targets
it'll provide clean electricity to power
the equivalent of around 11 400 homes
saving approximately 13 000 tons of CO2
every year over gas generation for
visualization one ton of CO2 is
approximately eight meters cubed
or one passenger flying from London to
Boston and then returning again so quite
substantial when you're considering it's
just 13 000 times of saving every year
it includes extensive landscape
proposals to improve habitat for
wildlife calculators deliver a
biodiversity net gain of 141 percent
and the site comprises entirely of
subgrade 3B which is not best the most
versatile agricultural land furthermore
agricultural operations will continue on
the site through sheep grazing during
the operations and solar farm
the site is already well screened from
established vegetation surrounding with
the opportunities for additional
screening and break-in reviews by
planting additional trees and hedgerows
within the site
wildflowers and species-rich grassland
were replaced intensibly farmed Fields
allowing soil to rest and rejuvenate
from the use of pesticides and
fertilizers as well as providing a
stable store of carbon
we have actually engaged the local
community and held an online webinar in
September 2021
we've also met with local residents on
an individual basis one minute left the
main takeaway from this exercise is that
local local people would refer to see a
solar farm than a new Housing
Development
it should also be noted that ready Town
Council do not object to the application
in accordance with the office of
recommendation we ask that members
approve the supplying application which
is policy compliant and I was detailing
the application will have extensive
public benefits thank you
thank you Mr wine and if you'd like to
take a seat again
uh now it's turn of uh this is your
weight
if you'd like to come to the chair and
you have five minutes and I'll
say
um microphone please
6.5 of the officers report will be
helpful paragraph 3.188 if you need to
refer to it
could you repeat those please page 6.5
paragraph 3.188
and also if you had the natural Inland
response handy that'll make things easy
so 3.188 on page 6.5
the pressure to achieve rdc's renewable
energy goals should not be used to
justify an industrial scale Solar
Development in the wrong location
rooftop solar offers the best
opportunity for a triple win climate
community and Countryside for the record
I'm here tonight objecting as a resident
I did go to the webinar in 2021 and I'm
also a Rayleigh Town councilor and I
objected to this application at our
planning committee in May 2022. I based
my objections Then and Now on the
following material considerations
this development is on our green belt
and on the best most versatile
agricultural land it fails to enhance
the landscape it fails to preserve Our
Heritage assets and the 40 year old oak
tree will be destroyed amongst others as
you could see by that access point the
mppf states that many renewable energy
projects are inappropriate and harmful
to the green belt where harm is
identified there should be a strong
presumption against approval in the
planning balance the green belt the
fundamental aim of the Greenbelt is to
prevent prevent urban sprawl and keep
land permanently open I.E nothing else
on it the solar arrays will immediately
harm the green belt in terms of ground
cover due to the sheer quantity of them
ask yourselves this question is this
development essential for our district
this Council has already approved two
industrial scale solar developments that
are already producing 70 megawatts of
Renewal Energy you're at 70 already
there are three more pending this
community's consideration one in rourith
one in fanbridge and this one all on
agricultural land please consider this
cumulative impact to our Green Belt
enough is enough
the paragraph I said about we shouldn't
be made to choose between food or
renewable energy production our district
can have both sixty percent of our food
is imported our will land is in Decline
and yields are reducing due to the
global warming impact on land quality to
quote the Secretary of State great
importance is placed upon our
Agriculture and food production any
proposal involving the best and most
versatile agricultural land would need
to be justified by the most compelling
evidence the land survey by the
applicant classified it as sub-grade 3B
however Natural England says the
opposite they confirm that this
application is likely to affect the best
and most versatile agricultural land
Natural England also questions whether
this is an effective use of land as
planning guidance encourages the
sighting of these developments on
Brownfield and non-agricultural land I
ask you to put significant weight on
natural England's View and Motley
resident the applicants landscape
planning inspectors recognize that
industrial scale solar developments
undermine the unspoiled character and
appearance of the landscape they have
upheld Council refusers on that basis
look at the view from great weekly Farm
the occupier of that farmers on
understandably objected to this
application the historic buildings and
conservation report you receive confirms
that this development will give an
industrializing effect contrary to the
agricultural State landscape setting
resulting in harm to the green belt
that's enough to refuse this application
as well
the heritage site as open arable land is
considered to positively contribute to
Historic Farmstead and the designated
Heritage assets within it the historic
buildings report says this scheme fails
to preserve the special interest of
listing buildings through the change in
the setting I.E from open land to
regimented intrusive rows of hard
surface solar panels their report is
clear public benefit would have to
outweigh the harm for each asset there's
three assets
the secretary of state has already
confirmed that even if limited to 30
years reversibility should not be an
influential factor in the
decision-making process and should be
given little weight this is for 40 years
the campaign for Rural England's
protection is clear Grays and Chief and
beekeeping are token gestures
burden back deaths are common as they
mistake the glass for water and the land
would degrade as half of it is going to
be in permanent shadow
planning policies and decisions should
protect contribute and enhance the
natural local environment this will
enhance nothing with the Holt Farm tree
we all remember that one minute RDC had
no official power to stop its
destruction it was not within your
control
with this oak tree and all the other
trees they want to fell as well Maple
Oak Sycamore Birch you can stop this the
cumulative impact to the landscape and
farmland must carry substantial weight
please consider this in your decision
this evening and one final Point next
week you're all voting to declare a
climate and ecological emergency please
bear that in mind start early start now
thank you
[Music]
can I start by asking if there are any
visiting members who need would like to
speak
no one indicating okay
award members
councilor Lawman I believe is the only
member here so uh do you have anything
what to say yes sir okay I hope I'm
close enough thank you uh if you could
be with me in your Indulgence I'm trying
to refer to comments made within the
report
so before I start obviously I'm very
familiar with this site and I've I've
been walking that area with other
neighbors for some time so I have a I
have a good idea what's going on and I'd
like to refer you to 316 on page 616 and
there's a comment in there probably four
or five lines down and it says
although there is a where are we oh
there we are in review of the council's
policies relating to Greenbelt
development policy gb1 Greenbelt
protection reflects the national
apologies which Prevail at the time and
are not changed at this time in terms of
their fundamental prison principles and
objectives
I heard the comment Shane about being a
significant value
um where is it significant it's a it's
something that's been placed in to
gather uh electricity for the country if
you like and uh and I think it's more
more about money than it is as a
significant value so I would challenge
their comment but then I want to go on
to 619
I think yes item 328 and it says there
with my neither the framework nor the
adopted local plan provide guidance as
to what compromises very special
circumstances VC VSC either singly or in
combination however some interpretation
of VSC has been provided by the courts
and it goes on to tell you about very
special circumstances I see I simply
haven't heard anything that produces
this to me is very special circumstance
and I come to my appointment I finished
if I make German
then we go to page six two three three
one three point four seven it says in
conclusion it's suspicion of the
benefits the submission acknowledges
there will be impacts namely the
openness of the greenbuilt Heritage Farm
a home and Landscape home
right
so taking these matters in turn
paragraphs 147 and 148 the mppf state
that inappropriate development the green
belt is by dead definition harmful and
Carries of substantial weight
and then it goes on it's clear that many
energy projects will compromise
inappropriate development this is in the
report
so then
um we come on to if I may
I've got five I'm sure I've got far more
points here sorry
I'm looking at the pages six two I've
done that one
then I come to 639 I do apologize
about the glare and there's a comment
there one at three point one three one
at the bottom is 639 so I can't
pronounce all the words were
particularly reflective I'm not
particularly reflective but if you read
that the other way that means they are
reflective and so I want to take it to
my point in principle really that um
because it goes on in some detail that I
walk that area I'm very familiar with
the area and when you compare this to
the already suggested solar platform
that we have that is on a flat plane
this is on a raised environment and
people say I've been there and I've been
in people's Garden so to say that they
won't have a visual impact is insulting
so I've seen that and I can look over to
the vines and I could look on the field
in fact I bought the field just for fun
but the thing is that it will have an
impact I see also in the report it's
going to have a security fence of 2.1
well the pain was understand three
meters high according to that then
you've got containers in there so to
suggest that this will be unobtrusive or
you know and suddenly hidden in the
fields is completely wrong it's also
placed in a very very
open Iceberg you've got main roads going
by you've got houses above you've got
Junctions in the corner
um and of course at one end they have
the what they call the playground area
further up the road but the thing is
that you've got walks and woods
I just feel that this is just as almost
as if it's like Lane grabbing and it's
being put in the emotional appropriate
price now I'm all in support of
renewable energy I'm all in support of
getting our country and our who got an
issue in this town and in this district
with air quality and other things
well I don't have a problem is just
switching the light on so I think that
this particular project will be
inappropriate and adverse to the people
living in that area and I think it's a I
can't support this application because I
think it's completely in the wrong place
um
and in the wrong conditions of people up
above I did talk to some members earlier
about that's what what they thought of
films and they said oh we've got one
over at Cambridge or wherever it was and
we looked down on it and it looks like a
boat filled but one expression who wants
to sit in your bedroom and look down on
a burnt field so um and there's a slight
glimmer and it looks like water well I'm
sorry I don't agree with that and the
people that people in Raleigh needs to
be respected we've taken enough
um you know impact on our town as it is
with other projects and I think this
just steps over the line and I don't
think it's appropriate and I can't
support this application
thank you
do we have any other members okay
Council Shelton Who
thank you chairman uh also a uh award
counselor for weedley Ward and um I've
seen the sites from the end of great
weekly Road
um I didn't have a particular view one
way or the other uh before attending the
meeting I've heard the argument from
both sides and
um I have come to the conclusion that um
this potentially will be an eyesore as
it is sloping land as councilor Lawman
said so the view from the end of great
we wrote will be very much affected
um by and also a number of of trees I
think mature trees will have to be
destroyed in the process of building
this Farm
um the benefits of renewable energy are
well known this isn't particularly
efficient 30 megawatts I guess is the
total capacity when the sun is shining
so that's certainly not all year round
and it's certainly not 24 hours a day
30 megawatts is the equivalent of uh of
five wind turbines
um four or five wind turbines so in that
sense wind renewable energies is far
more efficient
um I think it will be an eyesore it's
the wrong place I'm all in favor of
solar PV but uh
at source ideally on the roof of houses
or Social Clubs
or anywhere like that as long as it's
not in the conservation area of course
so I'm totally in favor of um solar PV
in the right place and I don't think
this is the right place thank you
thank you
[Music]
um
I think they uh will you you spoke about
the trees but you said you'd come back
to it you made no mention of the loss of
the trees what number trees and why they
were being removed perhaps you could go
into that into a little bit detail in a
moment
um also you spoke about the working
hours with the site was being done as
being seven days a week
um if this was to be granted approval I
would object to those working hours
um and you didn't mention you said about
the construction entry
um you haven't mentioned whether there's
going to be any speed restrictions on
that Entry Road to to facilitate the
construction perhaps you could go into
detail on those three items for me
please
I'm afraid the slides have let me down
so I haven't been able to show you
everything that I do need to show you
unfortunately so what was that can you
just repeat what the first question the
first issue was please
it was on the trees you did say in your
uh talk that you would come back to the
set the the trees but you didn't make
any mention within your talk about what
trees are going and what the loss of
those trees are to the area at all so in
paragraph 3.14
the revisions to the axis affects group
one which forms a little can I just read
this because our members can refer to
3.154
we are getting towards the two and a
half hour Mark
um can I ask can I say I'd like to move
a motion uh without notice according to
committee procedure rule nine uh to
extend this meeting Beyond two and a
half hours for as long as necessary in
order to complete this item
second all in favor
we'll put those against them
any abstentions
[Music]
okay seven four three against so we are
going to extending the meeting hopefully
not for too long
back to you all sorry
trance this the best they can
sorry I'm just going to refer to 3.154
now
the revision to the axis affects group
one which forms a linear belt of ash
black than Elder Hawthorne succulent
wild cherry on the other one two seven
but I I'm really not getting where the
loss of soap tree is coming in
because somewhere in the report tells
the report that there's not going to be
loss of any significant trees because
they've been categorized
um and there's no neither has been
objection so our aborticultural
consultant James George has seen these
revised plans he's commented on the
plans and he's got no objection to these
plans
so in terms of I think there is an area
but this paragraph here is mainly the
main paragraph that relates to trees now
they're affected and I don't know where
the speaking member of the party is is
extrapolating that there's going to be a
loss of an oratory
it's a suggestion chairman that we refer
this to the agent to clarify this matter
because I'm not aware of loss of autism
neither is our Consultants Aboriginal
James chose
are you suggesting then that we defer
I'm obsessed with the fur but I'm not
getting where these lots of trees is is
being
um
as far as we're concerned
there isn't going to be any significant
loss of trees only surgeries of low
grade
um low grade trees which are growing
along the side of the road there's no
sort of significant Orchestra is being
fouled in connection with this
development
that is my understanding I'm not really
clear on what you're asking for the
suggestion is is the trees are being
foul doesn't say the connection the
construction access I'm not aware of any
trees other than what's mentioned there
being filed the law grade small round
small gray trees like shrubs within the
Hedge line I don't know whether
reference to the oak tree is actually
coming from
sorry sorry we can't we can't take
anything from the public I'm sorry about
this
if I can just clarify a paragraph
3.154 talks about certain Works to trees
but not removal
three points
[Music]
yeah what I'm being informed is it works
to the trees not loss of the trees I'm
sorry I know members of the public
really want to actually contribute on
this but it's not the position that I
can accept that I'm afraid sorry about
that but that's just who is
um
so I'm not seeing that that is being a
material consideration in what we can
actually consider well it does say at
the bottom of that that the the road may
affect the root which would affect the
tree perhaps some condition could be
looked at that that those ropes could be
protected there's already conditions
there is yeah okay
okay the other thing was on the working
hours and speed restrictions
okay anyone else
all of a sudden uh Council Hawaii oh
sorry oh sorry councilor Stanley
thank you chairman
um
on my
inspection of the site this was some
time ago uh with uh mic strengths
um there's a large area between the
Grapevine
and the second half of the field that
has got solar always proposed to have
solar panels
all those trees in that area
um
I think if you brought up the solar
panel Farm itself I could describe where
those trees are that we are we are
talking about
there is a vast number of trees and
shrubs and also in the area
um could you bring up the numbers please
and that will be helpful okay so in
frame five where you see that there is a
vast area of trees to the border of that
and there is a like that ditch that runs
there a Hedgerow and so on in number
three and number two they're all several
trees in those areas
which are which are mature trees they
are enormous but they would be in my
garden anyway
um
and they're in a field and they don't
seem to be there and I did ask that we
would the committee should have an
aerial view of the site complete aerial
view not as it stands like that as it
stands at the moment and I did
specifically ask for that
um
and it wasn't it doesn't seem to have
materialized uh this would help us a
great deal in in deliberation
um but obviously it's not going to help
the way these have been put together
thank you
so just hang on a minute I'm just asking
a bit of advice here
okay we'll come back to that in the
meantime
um uh Council Hawaii
um thank you before I I start commenting
I can help with the um
issue around the removal of the oak tree
it's in one of the reports to the um
which are online
cultural method statement Southeast grid
storage 2 limited
um table eight on
page 10-ish
if I can get to that sorry is it in the
report tree works
tree works for reason of Public Safety
all three work referred to here it must
be carried out prior to any site
Personnel Community works for any
building material being delivered
table eight summary of tree Works number
20 species common oak filter ground
level grind out stump
if you look online and going to the
documentations that provided
right so the comments we haven't been
privy to that because obviously when I
come to a meeting I tend to look at all
documents or as many documents as
possible so it's a report probably not
in front of most people here and many
people I've seen it because a lot of
people rely on the on the officer report
but it's clearly states that it's going
to be felt to ground level and grind
outstand
others it's got other ones as well um G4
various partial removal of brute filters
within the alignment of a proposed
access track grind out stamp to prune
Crown Lift remaining trees to achieve
five meter clearance which is what we
referring to about works on them but it
certainly refers to further trees being
removed but there's number 20 common oak
felt ground level it's quite clear
that will be happening can I just make
an appeal to members that if you
actually find information on this which
is pertinent to this that you uh alert
us beforehand because I think this would
have been very sorry chairman this is
this is a report available to everybody
on our planning website for this
application it is part of the
documentation for us to consider at this
meeting that's the problem
so um I didn't know that people weren't
aware of it it's on the planning site
okay understood
um cancer Lefty
yeah thanks chairman
um what's my last couple of questions
and a couple of points but listening
listening to what's being said about
status in reports what we haven't seen
and Mr Warwick's presentation we've had
problems with the presentation
could we maybe move this to next meeting
and actually get the presentation
working properly to make a decision on
this properly
I'll take advice on that in a minute
um I have a question I question I had on
this
other than that is
the special Circumstance the world has
asked us we've got a climate emergency
in the world so this is one of the
things we can do to hopefully help with
that
um with the
question Forest Orwell where I've been
looking at the
3.189 where it gives the classifications
of soil and he says that
area with grade 3B
which is a subgrade soil so I don't
quite understand where people are saying
it's very good soil it's it's not which
is in the report if that's correct
is that those correct yes there are
three grades of agricultural land higher
in land classification value than 3B
thank you
um
yeah probably Net Zero powering out
homes powering out businesses it's close
to our homes and businesses
I haven't got a problem with solar be
really nice to have them on houses but I
can imagine the logistics are trying to
organize a thousand houses to put so the
one we'd never get it done by 2050. so
I'm in favor of this
so I'm just going out there but I still
think we should have
better information because a lot of the
report was on there
okay thank you for that uh Council Shaw
thank you chairman on post 6.41
so if you've got it
um
3.140 it is understood that commencement
of this project is due to start in late
2022 this is the fairground interchange
and will be completed in 2024 at the
time of preparing the planning
submission the applicant states that it
is anticipated that the construction of
the solar farm would begin after the
highway Improvement works are completed
there is no date as yet set out to get
the fair blend interchange
improvements done so I think this part
that part of the report is completely
Incorrect and I've just had it confirmed
by Essex highways as I'm Deputy okay I'm
going to bring the officer back on that
one please
specifically in regards to that question
the timing of The faglan Interchange was
discussed with Matt Lawrence and that is
why there's a condition that covers
the events
um I'll refer to the condition now
so I think the issue is if I'm correct
uh cancer shot is is that what would
happen if the fairground interchange was
lagging behind that this development
took place before the fairground
interchange so that issue was discussed
in detail with a developer highways and
it's covered by a condition I believe
it's I just bear with their numbers
there's a specific condition on this and
I'll try and find it now
um
[Music]
that covers that event
uh
something somewhere in the higher
conditions 14 15.
artificial use of access points should
just works destroying
I can't identify it within the condition
was definitely covered here somewhere
because we discussed it in detail and
it's been agreed with the developer
um in terms of if I could ask perhaps
the the agent to confirm which condition
that was because we agreed them with
each with each other
is to cover that eventuality of of
um ensuring that if that isn't done then
it coincides uh the work is done
summer it's 0.6 page six six or six
seven
um it's either condition 18
or uh
can I ask the agent to confirm because
it's one of these conditions but I can't
identify which one it is as the way it's
worded please
can I suggest then that you just go and
have a chat with him now and bring it
back to us
in the meantime
[Music]
microphone please
I will remember one day Trevor I'm sure
I should be used to these
um on the base that I believe Council
Rafferty has suggested we defer the item
to get further information and to get a
better a
more flowing wolf or a working report
from the officer I was second his
motion to defer because I think there's
information we need on the oak tree
definitely information we need on the
access point and the build point of this
in relation to the fair cleaning to
change
I also have
questions around
other other areas which
I was going to come on to but I can
leave that till we come back to the next
meeting so I'm justificating the motion
okay
just uh ask our officers to comment on
that particular
thank you Chad I think we just need to
check that that is a motion being made
but all the same members clearly within
their right to request more time to
consider things I would just set out
that whilst the presentation uh is
clearly being length lengthy and
detailed
um and we've had a few problems with the
slides the report itself is extremely
detailed and it does provide you enough
information to make a decision so the
presentation is to supplement the debate
and it's to supplement the report that's
in front of you and I would suggest that
that is sufficient enough to make a
decision here and there's been a number
of points raised around information uh
Fair Glen interchange I think the point
being made on Fair Glenn is that the
scheme could come forward regardless of
whether the fair Glenn scheme comes
forward and that we've had comments back
from the highway authority to confirm
that it's sufficient in that terms we've
had comments made about very special
circumstances there is a significant
chunk of this report that sets out the
very special circumstances that are
considered so there are a number of
questions here that are answered in the
report so I would suggest that the
information is sufficient to make a
decision but clearly members can decide
whether or not they need more time to
make that decision
sorry chairman if I may I would suggest
that there are discrepancies in the
report to what we're hearing there is no
mention and the officer doesn't isn't
even aware that there's a tree being
failed where it's clearly shown within
the documentation shown online so it is
whether or not the documentation online
is correct or whether the officer's
report is correct around the felling of
a tree the
the
confusion around
the report and the access point
has been dealt with but it just doesn't
give us
enough comfort
given that these discrepancies also over
the
quality of the land Natural England
disagree with the 3B rating they rate it
better
again if you look at the report online
that Natural England put in
they rate it better and that's not said
in this report so I
there are discrepancies and I think they
need to be dealt with
[Music]
our officers would like to just come
back please
so on the agricultural land class
data that are the councils obtained
that's Ordinance survey data it's a
shape file as we shape file GS GIS data
so I would suggest that the council's
records on the agricultural land
classification is actually correct as
opposed to Natural England's View and on
the um just picking up on the
um alleged discrepancy with the Felon of
the oak tree I just would remind members
that you know if there is an admission
in the report that there's an oak tree
to be filled we need to think about the
wider benefits that this actually
application is actually presenting for
the community for the District of
Rochford and The Wider benefits that are
being achieved by such a large renewable
energy scheme so and I think that coming
back on the point that councilor Lawman
made about the two existing trees that
were in the fields that you've witnessed
yourself in the paragraph above at 3.153
it does actually state that the existing
trees that are in those fields the solar
panels will be set back from those trees
so obviously those trees would cast a
shadow on those solar panels so
um this actual mention of those trees
actually in the real report so um as
just to compare and what um
feels actually Mr drains actually
um suggested to you is that there is
sufficient information within the report
to actually further committee to
actually make a decision on this
application tonight
we have
um
councilor Hawaii has suggested a motion
for deferral
um now sorry councilor FD did can I have
a secondary
okay
so then we have to take a vote on that
um before we take the vote does anyone
want to talk on the deferral
Council along
hey chairman um I never thought with a
referral but um just bring up a subject
to be considered in that uh
proposal is that if I've got it wrong
I'll be corrected but with the
interchange the proposals I thought they
were having another line on the a127 and
there was a flyover going from the a1245
or whatever it is coming down the other
side that would all affect this plan
because it would affect the entries and
exits of this property so perhaps you
could know a little bit more about that
if we could please
it
sorry yes I will come back
yeah I did say in my presentation that
this scheme does coincide with those
fagler interchange improvements and that
was the purpose also partly of the road
stage one safety audit so
access to this site has not been
considered in isolation to the fail and
interchange improvements that they
coincide so
the road safety order would fail if it
had failed to take the taken into
account those wide infrastructure
improvements so that they don't sell
into one another and that was the
purpose of trying to show the brand line
and the green line the the sort of the
the edge of the roadside so one hasn't
been conceived
irrespective of of the other and vice
versa that's the best I can explain it
thank you Council of course thank you
german yes I'd like to
um uh speak against uh deferring this I
think we've got enough in the report
um I've seen the site as as councilor
Lawman as has councilor Stanley as house
counselor Lyndon we know there's trees
on the site that will be filled the
online report is there that shows trees
that will be filled and I think it
mentions eight oak trees we've just
looked at aerial photographs showing
several trees so I think we've got
enough to vote on the the main
application and there's no need to do in
my opinion
okay thank you
anyone else want to talk on the motion
okay councilor Stanley
thank you chair I I don't know
has anyone read
6.61 and 6.62
of the
application
uh 6.61 and 6.62
there is information there
that
and
again I don't want to defer this but
this information there is has got would
have detrimental impact upon the setting
of these listed buildings it also in
conclusion development is considered to
constitute inappropriate development
within the metatronic bulletin ring belt
and is harmful by definition sorry was
the Stanley point of all the chairman
group please this is votes being put on
the table it's been seconded this is not
talking to
emotion we have to stick with the motion
although although the motion is busy fur
again I agree with councilor sharp at
the end
um that that you see no reason why we
should
okay we have a motion to defer
um can I have an indication of those who
are in favor please
[Music]
thank you those against
yeah
any abstentions
no no
we have three four motion to defer 9
against that that motion is lost
uh will carry on uh I'm very aware of
the time
um so I'm going to restrict the amount
that we're going to be talking about
this uh councilor hallway
you've done apologies okay
cancel it
thank you chairman I know I've spoken a
lot but I actually haven't said what I
came here to say
um
on the face of it this is an application
that fulfills a lot of the climate
change agenda I agree with that but it
would seems to be fairly obvious that it
would be approved
however and I will be bringing a folder
report on climate emergency and economic
climate a climate and ecological
emergency next week but I believe
there's a right place in the wrong place
for solar parks
um I'm looking at the office's report to
the papers submitted as well as the mppf
and the paper submitted online right not
just the office report I do have some
concerns
there appears to be an acceptance the
most recent of which I can find is a
February 23
inspectors report where the supply of
electricity from a site May provide the
special circumstances that can that can
outweigh outweigh the weight given to
that of the green belt
um and that's been mentioned tonight not
that case but that
that point
um
in the cases I've found in the previous
one in the district fanbridge the
generation of electricity has been
around 49.9 megawatts which is the
maximum they can apply for Planning
Commission for
enough power to
enough power to power around 16 000
homes this one
yeah I'm just reading what I've typed
very recently this however which I've
been typing tester anyone says I've been
typing it as we've had the meeting it's
not pre-typed and that's why it's not
perfect this site however is generating
around 30 megawatts around a third less
than those mentioned and enough to
repair around 11 000 homes and all that
these this is going to the grid so I
think we can't mention Community here
because it's not going to the local
community it's going to the National
Grid
um so the question arises from that is
what Mega watch does the production of
electricity not outweigh the special
circumstances of the green belt and I
think that's a question that we as a
council probably need to answer and I
don't know if this is the right place
for that
um my concern is that the site
isn't producing enough electricity
to outweigh those special circumstances
on this basis
um
I'll just move into biodiversity
[Music]
to know to a nice track there the
developers promised a net gain of about
141 I think it was which is good we
can't argue with that but when you're
talking about net gains from
a farmer's field they're always going to
be quite High because there isn't a lot
of biodiversity on a farmer's field
um and there are schemes there for
planting and attracting wildlife and I
know that there will be a breed and
planting before the production of
electricity but I do have concerns about
the maintenance of this over the life of
the scheme how the management and the
grades will be managed I know it's
mentioning the conditions but there are
specifics which I'm not sure how they'll
manage there is a suggestion when you
look on
um nationally that sheep perhaps can be
used to graze it but but they should
certainly shouldn't be used in the
the um Spring and Summer for instance so
I'm not sure if that's in how detailed
that will get and I think that's
important and also I was going to say
which comes to the trees I'm not sure
how much this outweighs the trees
being chopped down including an oak tree
um
and also I've got here which is why I
know about it again there's disagreement
over the quality of land with natural
income grading it better than the
applicant 3B which again goes back to
the confusion if we have a statutory
consultation saying it is better than
the applicant and we're saying we're
saying we disagree with natural England
we're always being told we can't
disgrune it statutory constantly
um so I want to know when we can and
when we can't
um so overall I have concerns that the
arguments for the site could be used for
all languages in the green belt as well
but there's not a single field in this
District that these arguments couldn't
be used for and that we we would
therefore have to put a solar
um development on
um also I'm not sure about whether the
cumulative impact was dealt with
satisfactory in the report
um we have a target of 100 100 megawatts
production by 2030 I think we're now at
70 of that I'm also I think there's a
number of sites in the process of
planning
that aren't being taken account of here
um
also further the officer's comments in
paragraph 3.25
which is on what should I put page
number four you apologies for that
3.25 on page 6.18
and I'm paraphrasing this on what not
quoting item for item but it says the
perceived openness of the green belt was
largely been eroded by the existence of
existing built infrastructure including
the construction of the a127 and the
railway line I'd just like to point out
that the land was originally designated
Green Belt the railway and the 127
already existed they weren't subsequent
to it being green bell I think we all
know that 127 was one of the first dual
carriers raised in the country built in
the 20s
um so that that's a little bit
misinformation there
um
and they therefore cannot diminish The
Waiting Givens Greenbelt as it was as
the Green Belt was designated in earlier
so due to these reasons and also
agreement to some of the comments made
by Council Norman I'm not convinced that
the various very special circumstances
exist for the development Trail outweigh
that other green belt
so I I'm mind you at this moment to vote
against
[Music]
okay thank you I'm minded to bring this
debate to a close if I could allow one
more Council yeah the
um working restrictions if this site was
to be allowed
um hasn't been addressed nor the speed
restriction on the road which I asked
about and I would like to put a
condition on that if this site was to go
ahead the working stopped at lunchtime
on Saturday and there was no Saturday
afternoon or Sunday working soon if this
was allowed
um
so if you come back on that please
somebody understanding is so condition
six within the um recommendation so
understanding is is that there's a
a proposal to mend the working hours at
weekends then
so we've got a
[Music]
um
so the condition is number six on page
6.3 and what it limits sorry
edition six on page 6.3
if you have a look at the hours are on
there
so at the minute what we've put forward
is a restriction of between half past
seven and half past six Monday to Friday
and 8 30 to 1 Saturday and Sunday and
now if members are unhappy with with the
weekend working for example this Sunday
um it may be the case that we can
perhaps remove the Sunday the Monday to
Friday I say is a more average time that
we have for working hours during the
week
um along with the Saturday half eight to
one that's a quite common type
um time frame on a Saturday for for
working but if you're unhappy with a
Sunday that might be something that
could be removed
supposed to be
okay so if we were looking to go down
the line of approval we could remove the
Sunday out effect Edition I think would
be reasonable thank you yeah
yeah okay thank you I've just got a few
things that uh I
sorry
the speed restriction was there anything
on on the road thing for a speed
restriction during the construction
phase of the main
um access road on onto the one two seven
yes
[Music]
I can't com I can't confirm in terms of
the speed restriction all I know is it's
been designed in terms of the speed of
traffic and the decelerate deceleration
and acceleration Lanes but I haven't
seen anything stating what the actual
speed on that high will be will this be
something on a post or something written
on the road all that has been designed
with all speed restrictions in mind but
I don't have a figure for the speed
[Music]
thank you I think that one would be
quite difficult to actually mandate on I
think if I'm honest I think I'm right on
that just a few things I just wanted to
say on it I've listened to all the
arguments I find this this
um this application
are quite interesting because on the
face of it it's
um
a very green
uh proposal
um and there are a number of conflicts
that I find you know even in the
arguments are going to do so one of the
things that I think has stood out to me
is the classification of the lamp being
3B and we've heard from our officers
that we've got the classification that
has been done as recorded scientifically
Natural England in their comments they
haven't come back with the
classification that they actually think
it is
they've just come back and said they
think it's better
and when we when we're actually in a
situation where we're considering facts
I think that's important
um
the the other thing is I think it's a
very good
um
uh
kind of um
Vision to have for having rooftop
panels but that is more of a policy
issue that I think that we can probably
as councilors take forward to a
different meeting
so I think that that may be something
that we can bear in mind and take away
from this meeting
[Music]
um
I'm quite
torn by the fact that the friends of the
Earth
are actually looking at this as a
positive
and so I I find it
quite difficult to actually get
so many conflicting
sort of areas of people who are
green-minded
actually giving a completely different
View
on this so I've got to be honest I'm
looking at what I'm seeing in the
officer's report
and I'm not sure that I can vote against
it
um
the advantages on this when you look at
11 000 odd houses that this is going to
power up one of the things when I was
looking at this I looked through
um the percentage of energy produced in
the UK and when you bear in mind that we
need to become energy self-sufficient
I'll give you this this is quickly coal
is 3.1 oil is 36.4 gas is 39.6 nuclear
is 6.1 percent bio energy and waste 8.9
wind 4.1 solar 0.7 Hydro or natural 0.3
over 0.8 so we have got a mountain to
climb if we are going to get to being
energy sufficient self-sufficient in
this country and I think I look at this
and I personally I think that
um yeah in the great scheme of things
it's not big
but every step we take
towards getting uh energy
self-sufficient has got to be a positive
yes I understand that there are concerns
about Greenbelt
um I do accept the officers uh report
where it says that the land is grade 3B
um I find it quite
um strange that Natural England haven't
come up with a counter argument on that
and I am green-minded
but I'm looking at this and I'm thinking
well this is going to contribute to our
um sustainability
um and at the end of the day I think
that
um I'm coming down on the side of
thinking that this this should actually
go ahead
uh to that mind I'm going to propose
from the chair that we
um recommend acceptance
of the uh
the report and um
[Music]
before we vote I'll just allow one more
from oh sorry you're a second here okay
thank you so
um
from the chair all those in favor
of this application please indicate
okay
those against
[Music]
those abstaining
the numbers are four is three against is
six and abstentions are three so that
motion is or the application is refused
sorry
oh yeah we know now we need to go to the
interesting one on um did any would
anyone like to actually propose the
reasons for refusal which we will need
to be using at appeal which I do
underline to you need to be solid
counselor
microphone please
sure he's helping councilor Constable
with his microphone will notice I need
to sit next to her next time
um
I there are a number of grounds
um I don't have necessarily the mppf
paragraph in front of me I think 151 is
important that
in in relation to
paragraph 151 we
there isn't a presumption that solar
sites like this should be
pushing the ring belt and that
we I don't believe that we don't believe
that the generation of 30 megawatts is
enough of a special circumstance
or or enough to outweigh the special
circumstances of Greenbelt
that's essentially it
catalog hey German I also consider it
over development I think it's um not in
keeping with the the general area you
know because of the impact it will have
on the residents all around nearby and
the and the impact it will have on the
visual effects
um when we go there I do agree also
there's I've been convinced this has
over significant uh case so
um that would be another one but the
other thing is of course I think that
it's a question of values and I think
that I think the value of the local
residents is hired and the issue is
concerned thank you
[Music]
have an assistant there thank you
um I think again in relation to the
outline and the special circumstances of
Greenbelt I think the fact that the
Heritage assets are also regarded as I
think it was put in the report was
moderate value
together with the fact that the green
the green building itself
is
good horribly exact wording used can I
just come back on the
um effects on the impact on the Heritage
asset we've got a consultation response
from Place services that does
acknowledge that there is harm then it's
judged to be less than substantial harm
and the mppf at paragraph 202 actually
states that that harm can be outweighed
by public benefit and it's been
demonstrated that in the officer's
report that there is that public benefit
by the actual
um delivery of the solar farm
yeah I understand that but it's another
point the point I'm trying to make is
that the the the generation of the power
the 30 roughly 30 megawatts is not
sufficient to outweigh the homes as long
as you're yeah
as a reason for refusal because they're
just making you aware that of the ones
I've seen and the families run as well
and the one which came forward in the
inspections reported in February 23 it
was clearly stated that the the solar
Farms they are out were at the maximum
they're at 49.9 megawatts and they and
the generation of that outweighed a very
special circumstances of green belt yeah
whereas this is a third less and that's
why I I'm putting that forward as a
reason for refuse that isn't sufficient
so we'll just stick to that reason for
refusal then that it's that this amount
of power had been generated doesn't
outweigh the harm to the green belt yeah
that's really quite clear yeah so we are
we content that we all got one reason
for refusal on that basis uh I think
I've just heard from councilor Myers
wants to contribute the only thing I'd
like to bring up is Sir section of 3.203
on my report page six point five three
and it actually says in concluding on
the acceptability of this proposal the
development in summary is considered to
constitute inappropriate development
within a much Metropolitan Greenbelt and
is therefore harmful definition
are you including that in reasons for
refusal
yes yes can you just repeat that then so
as that can be
sorry which which paragraph Was that
again it's on page 6.53 and it's power
off 3.203
and the wording for
your refusal but it actually is direct
from the report it says in concluding on
the acceptability of this proposal the
development in summary is considered to
constitute inappropriate development
within the Metropolitan Greenbelt and is
harmful by definition
even taking it taken into account that
you minimized harm it may be causing
okay can I suggest then that officers
repeat back uh the items that we are
suggesting for refusal so we are very
clear please thank you chair my
suggestion would be that we we do not
add
several reasons for refusal I think the
appeal of Defending and appeal would be
easier to have one clear reason or as
few clear reasons as possible I think in
the case of saying that it's
inappropriate development within the
green belt that is fact that is why it's
in the report that the report goes on to
say the things that outweigh that
situation so I think we're in we need to
Define why we think it's an appropriate
development in the green belt and I
think coming back to council La Hoya's
Point that's probably something that we
can base
um a defense around compared to just
having that on its own
okay going on that then can you just uh
read to us what you will be putting in
for the reasons refusal that we are
putting forward please
okay just talk about yourself a minute
[Music]
thank you chairman
um I'm concerned that we're only putting
that one reason as per suggestion if
that fails we've got no full bank and I
still feel that there is other
objections to this that should be heard
and you can say what you like but I like
a reserve put on there that this is not
uh well I forgot what I told you now but
it's certainly an over development it's
got an impact in the amenity of to the
people who live nearby with the visual
you know effects um are not rather added
because I don't think one reason is
enough because if you fail on that one
reason we've got no fullback I'm sorry
for my I don't agree with that I think
that's I'm not sure that that's really a
material planning consideration
in relation to this over and above I
think we need to take the officer's
advice the special very special services
in the office of advice is that we do go
with one specific
um reason for refusal and that would be
the one that we could actually stand a
chance with
[Music]
use all that we're um we've put together
based on what's been raised tonight and
the development is considered to
represent inappropriate development in
the green belt contrary to paragraph
four 149 of the mppf and is not
considered to be outweighed by the
energy output of the solar farm
unless I hear any objections I will
um assume that that is the reason and
why we what we voted on last time we
were in agreement with them
they're great
hang on
um
refusal on that basis
okay we so you're proposing the refusal
on the basis of what we've read out can
we have a second up please
no I'm I'm advised that we have to have
a vote on the reason that is actually
written down and defined
okay
Council Stanley second
[Music]
okay well I don't want to prolong things
too long so I'll second The Proposal
thank you
so
are you speaking to the
no okay right then can I just ask that
do we read that out one more time so we
can be clear and then we'll vote on it
and hopefully that'll be in this evening
so the development is considered to
represent inappropriate development in
the green belt contrary to paragraph 149
of the mppf and he's not considered to
be outweighed by the energy output of
the solar farm
it goes in favor please indicate
okay hands down thank you uh those
against
foreign
[Music]
okay that is six four one against five
absentions so that is carried
thank you members and uh ladies and
gentlemen that's the end of the evening
the meeting is closed at 10 34.
[Music]